哇塞 台灣股市今天逆轉勝
拉高了717點
欸穩了嗎
雖然最後殺了一點點
但只是小小的翻黑
可是上規指數翻紅了
第二個 美伊又停火了
打打停停 停停打打
到底通膨有沒有解
本週的FED會議到底會不會升息
第三個 AI破解了
87年未解的數學難題
還在進步嗎
AI可以改變我們什麼生活
可以改變股價嗎
今天通通告訴你
今天一堆股票
藍雅科今天拉上去
環球青今天拉尾盤
跟你偷拉尾盤
官民震大人的拉
應該說官民震大人拉尾盤
這些股票代表的是
最後台股最後難關
已經渡過了嗎
所有表股介紹
我今天一次講個夠
台股真的太強了
今天早盤一度中錯600多點
不少投資朋友們又嚇壞了
结果尾盘买盘全面点火
指数一路暴力极拉
盘中一度翻红
最后小跌20点收在43,634点
而且投资涨的股票还是很强
环球金尾盘油黑翻红
低到高极拉了快6%
群联也差点就翻红
还有南亚科竟然油黑拉到差点涨停
真的太强了
投资涨这些股票这样拉
是不是代表台股最壞的情況
已經過去了呢
你手上還沒有標股嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長
投資長好
Lily 各位朋友們大家好
哎呀 我本來想說
砸那個跌破四萬點
是
這要砸個幾千萬
我先說好嗎
先起碼先來個五千萬
五千嗎
五千...
那七千萬也可以好不好
喔
如果破四萬點
先達個七千萬
我先講喔
不要說我沒說
哎呀 哲哲要先達七千萬
達七千萬如果今年
漲到四萬點買
然後漲到六萬點
哇 七千萬可以賺三千五百萬
哇
到時候再捐錢好不好
哲哲今年已經捐一台救護車
再捐也沒關係好不好
OK嗎
那個
再捐
就是明年的扣打
我希望每年
每年真的
我現在這隻還年輕嘛
我希望在我離開人世間的時候
就有22台救護車
台灣是22台23個縣市
隨便啦
whatever
好可惜喔
可是老天爺看起來
不賞我飯吃
那你們更有福啊
好不好
我跟大家講
我說今天很多股票拉尾盤
不過我跟你講就是一樣
破4萬點就是買
破4萬點就買
我跟大家講很多AI的東西好不好
我是全台灣最懂AI的分析師
記得
只有我
我們100萬粉絲可以作證
我們全台灣也是我唯一百萬粉絲嘛
135萬的粉絲
可以作證
只有我第一個講
AI股票會展一年
甚至展三年
只有我
在去年的時候
直接跟你講台灣股市會散三萬六
是
很多人還說胡扯
四雅你去找一下
好像某個財經主播
那個你去找Trader
搜尋哲哲
在12月的時候
你搜尋哲哲就可以
請四雅截圖
某個財經主播
東森財經主播
我還附上圖
幫我附個圖
他去年只有蜇蜇預估台灣股市3萬6
說我好大膽
等一下給你找證據
不用了 你等一下底下都可以留言
是不是只有蜇蜇
那我先跟大家講
你看今天南亞科很多拉起來
南亞科蜇蜇走了
好不好 走掉了
南亞科蜇蜇走掉了
可是
829群年
投資朋友
逢低的時候我該買就買
暗示什麼
還有6488環球金
你們看到一堆股票拉尾盤
是
環球金我說不用跌破1000元
我們講過
我本來說跌破1000元我要買
不用跌破1000元
這時候環球晶有加碼
加碼在哪邊
我跟你講一件事
絕對不是加碼到1100元以上
這就是你要的分析師
你們永遠看的是
不要說你們啦
失敗的人永遠看的是悲觀
永遠看是我怎麼倒楣
樂觀的人永遠看什麼
是運氣
是機會
opportunity
機會
我永遠看是機會
就讓我跌破4萬點 我要買
你看你今天找盤的時候
台灣股市是不是很悲觀
是
找盤股市的時候
你不要嚇死人了啦
殺下去你看
4萬2千
969點 有沒有看到
殺了快700點
Mamma mia
大盤今天殺下去耶
看起來要打第二根
就想說這這二是破底
我說第一個
基本上4萬2是底部了
我沒有說過 有
有
這邊是4萬2
4萬2這邊是底部
居然42000這邊是底部了
你其實你真的拉滾
你反而要進場
你在怕什麼
你在猶豫什麼
你不應該猶豫的
你應該是游刃猶豫的想
要買什麼股票
好
第二個我也跟大家講
我說最近是大家講去槓桿
全台灣第一個人講槓桿的是我
然後最討厭槓桿的也是我
之前很多網紅
喔 跟你吹嘘 鼓勵 借錢買股票
現在不敢講了
連個指都不敢講
這真的 從頭到尾
我也不要針對誰 我不會針對誰
我只知道很多人就叫你這樣槓桿
從頭到尾 絕對最不屑的就是叫你這種槓桿
我寧願少賺錢
我知道這樣少說很多會費 少說很多會員
我不在乎 因為我會員本來就很多
可是我要跟你是長成久久的
我要做長成久久
我也常常跟大家講
為什麼看折折看折折一集少一集
你看我現在爆爆爆停了
福利社停了
可是我就是為了要長長久久
是
因為我知道我也不能
我也知道我要給大家
我為了錢是給自己超級高壓
我現在給自己普通高壓
我才跟你們長長久久
所以你要珍惜每一天
跟我看節目的日子
好
我跟你就是要長長久久的
所以我不跟你推薦一些
很奇怪的觀念你知道嗎
連杠桿都不一樣
所以你看這正確觀點
所以很多我的粉絲會員
這幾天跌下去才發生很開心
而且我還是要講
我大聲講應該近期來
今年以來
績效全台灣績效最好還是我
為什麼
因為你們去比較別人
別家投過的分析師跟我
因為我的績實實在在的
我問大家一件事情
哪一個人可以秀出這麼漂亮的績效表
而且這些都是普通會員
我只秀普通會員
我不要跟你秀那種很奇怪的會員等級
不然我把台生哥也算進去
你們到底有沒有
這個參加人數很少
我不需要講
你懂嗎
聯發科賺了
有沒有 都賣4000多元有沒有
平均賣4000多元有沒有
國際賺快100%
環球金賺93%
金財賺92.9
是不是
是
帆軒賺快50%
維新賺20幾%
老實沒有
其實我覺得這個回答是好事
你知道什麼好事嗎
我買環球金買中美金的時候
我每天都怕被抓去關儲置
現在都不必怕了
你知道為什麼不必怕嗎
現在都沒有被關儲置的危機
實在幫我查一下
是沒有被關儲置的危機
有時候是成交量問題
成交量太大也會
基本上都已經取消儲置了
就是儲置至少要一個禮拜過後的事情
兩個禮拜過後的事情
所以你現在買
中時物大物醒過來的時候
股價會很噴出去喔
我還是要講
我是全堂上最了解AI的
為什麼了解AI
你看一下我今天做這些圖
等一下喔
今天這禮拜最重要是費得利率嘛對不對
對
你看費得利率
7月升級的可能性有沒有到
還告訴你7月會升級
不升級的機率是66%
9月升級的機率是超過57%
是
同時沒有
我做那麼多漂亮的圖
你告訴我哪個
每個人都會做AI的圖
為什麼是某個分析師
會做AI圖
基本上現在很少人找美邊做這些圖啦
為什麼某個分析是圖最漂亮
為什麼我們圖最漂亮
這是AI的深不深喜
黃仁星告訴你
晶片業的AI前景樂觀
這次不一樣有沒有看到
是整體產業的一個需求
有沒有看到
有
這些為什麼圖做得特別漂亮
還有
特斯拉的財報
有沒有看到
是不是
自由現金流量這個東西
跟你解釋一下
我解釋自由現金流量
是最無聊的
2008年的時候
我還記得一堆分析師
上财经节目跟你讨论
红海会不会倒闭
营业现金为负
我快笑死了
红海倒闭吗
那时候大家都讨论这些
那为什么我AI图都做得特别漂亮
特斯拉的财报
Alphabets Google的财报
为什么
我都清清楚楚告诉你
为什么我做的AI图特别漂亮
因为我懂AI
我懂AI
为什么我做懂AI
來 我們來看一下
Card of Fable 5
破解87年的數學嫌案
很多人現在數學都不用學了啦
很多數學家現在
真的也很辛苦也很可憐
你知道嗎
因為一般數學系的
你喔
就是好一點
你可能去做工程數學
華爾街
你知不知道
那一般來就是你當研究家
你知道嗎
當老師
像這種以前那種猜想可以的話
可以得諾貝爾你知道嗎
牙可比拆下
1939年這個奧特海因理事
凱樂提出來的有沒有看到
若牙比可
若牙可比含烈士
為非零纏數
映射是否全域可立
局部不塌陷
去推論全域可立
你聽懂嗎
每一個字你都聽得懂
全部加起來你都聽不懂
我也差不多
完全聽不懂耶
好
這數字要證明的
反正就是說
它要證明什麼
它要證明就是說
A.A.B.C
你要證明
要映射到不同點位
你知道嗎
結果他沒有
他直接舉出一個例子來就好
再舉一個反例就好
可是反例大家找不到
就是我只要舉出一個
你要全部的例子
你要做這個
你這個推論要正確
我直接跟你講
你推論要正確對不對
對
他說一定怎麼樣
那是不是我只要舉一個相反例子
是
否定你一直
可是否定你一直找不出來
我證明這件事情
我證明這件事情一定可以的
那我是不是要找一個反對例子
我只要找一個反對例子就可以了
沒錯
找不出來 87年數學家
所有的諾貝爾數學家講找不出來
然後結果Enthropic的AI模型
不好意思
他發現一個反例了
登登登登
就一個簡單反例
就是我
你說一定怎麼樣
我只要告訴你
有一個事情不是一定怎麼樣
這件事情一定不是這樣好不好
OK
他連高度的抽象數學問題都可以盡人潛力
很恐怖
就是數學有幾百個幾千個解讀的方式
大家找不到一個工具太多了
是
耗費能力太多了
所以你告訴我
這是數學
那你告訴我那些數學或一些化學的
有時候其實生物學也是一個化學公式而已
人體很複雜可是你以後去怎麼驗證我得癌症了癌症假設是癌又不同腫瘤每個人對應的都是不同腫瘤肝癌是肝癌喔
它可能有幾十種
可能假設好幾種
幾種是腫瘤
那你怎麼
你以前可能你要慢慢試
你現在可以用暴力解法
AI模擬這個環境
也可以
可以加速的解藥
所以我說你們真的很幸福
基本上你們只要80歲以內的人
都很幸福
越年輕的越幸福
因為在十年過後
越來越多的證據
跟你證明
因為在十年過後
人類的平均壽命
可能真的有機會
邁向90到100
現在是七八十歲
平均壽命嗎
有機會
可是在之前
你還是要保養身體
表示你血管差了
你看哲哲有看到
哲哲有變壯也變胖了
還是要像哲哲一樣
你要去重訓跑步
好不好
這更大 把身體養好
不要三高 血糖 血壓
這都可以吃藥了
血痰血壓還有什麼
血脂
這都可以吃藥的好不好
先從減重開始
好不好
把這些身體先不要養壞
你以後得一些癌症
睡眠好
你得一些癌症
很容易治好
一個87年的數學猜想
你看
你看牙殼筆猜想你知道嗎
只有紫紫做的圖
為什麼特別漂亮
這些老師懂AI嗎
為什麼不跟你解釋
這很恐怖耶
如果你是數學系的
就很恐怖耶
沒得混了你知道嗎
真的
你會覺得沒得混了
你知道嗎
不會啦 還是有需要啦
比如說我們工程數學啊
你懂不懂
那些比如說華爾街交易
一些微秒交易
還是比較懂數學的人比較好
只是說
職業空間越來越小
你知道嗎 職業空間
所以我跟你講
一些工作真的翻譯官啊 翻譯家啊
你要做翻譯的 真的
趕快轉行
相信我
你不知道怎麼轉行
先投資AI
做駕駛的 趕快
OK嗎
我是跟大家講
做駕駛
你該轉函要轉函
好不好
OK嗎 不然投資AI
這我都跟你講
做家家老師 補習班老師
該轉函要轉函
我是跟你講這幾個函限最容易被取代
好不好
數學家本來就很難找了
這次之後更難找
雅科比猜想
你看我隨便做這個東西就可以
有沒有想
哇 這是數學界吸血鬼
21世紀的十八大難題之一
你知道AI跟人差別是
AI20小時不休息啊
他智商比人內高啊
你懂什麼
現在已經死了 你懂嗎
唉
已經是了
你去看這件事情了
這東森某個
你看東森某個
這個
大家怎麼稱呼他
達達媽
是不是
東森的主播有沒有
在去年12月3號的時候有沒有看到
這Trade可以收到
哲哲說台股是明年36000點
目前是投股圈最高很感慨的
總之大家的共識是30000點有沒有看到
有
那時候你自己看別家
你自己看 欸這是12月3號的值子喔
國泰四環銀行說突破3萬點
遜掉了
然後凱基投顧說3萬3
群英投顧說3萬4
中英投顧說3萬5
只有郭子龍說3萬6
我甚至說說4萬
沒有我投顧
是
這是我說的
其他分析師也都認同
有沒有看到
你看
那時候財經主播在去年12月的時候
有沒有看到
這也是東森的一線的主播
這折痕感寒
要搞清楚一件事
不是只能喊
I see the future
12月的時候
結果一下子
你們覺得現在財股很長
不好意思
還是4萬3 4萬4
是
那時候3萬6大家覺得我瘋了
所以財產股市的問題是長太多
要休息一下
那時候3萬6大家覺得我瘋了
沒有一家頭骨敢跟著喊
跟著某個頭骨喊
後來喊4萬
沒有人敢喊
我告訴你
我看的是未來
你們不要跟我小鼻子小眼睛
問我明天後天
我有few的時候我會跟你講
沒有few的時候我不知道
因為我現在我就不知道
可是我可以告訴你
台灣股市今年是不是會突破五萬點
因為進展太快你懂不懂
懂
去年前年AI拿著什麼牙科比猜想啊
什麼數學87年難題啊
不要鬧了
我跟你講
我看到這些振奮的
你看
只是智商也算不錯
可是你覺得那些更有錢的人
那智商會比我低嗎
當然不太可能嘛
我身價幾千億
我拿個100億人
然後我投資 AI 用的錢賺
然後我延長壽命10年
你要不要做
當然要
當然要做那些錢我花不完
所以你們怎麼去 AI 泡沫
我沒有回報我不在乎
我有夢啊
真的有夢啊
那些人就是很無聊
我看不出來資本支出
我看不到回報
你們看的是小鼻子小眼睛
你們看一兩季的事情
我看的是未來
I see the future
我看是十年後
台灣平均人民的壽命
可不可以增加10年 20年
健康的增加10年 20年
為什麼不投資
這在想什麼東西啊
看那些財報就像我講的
為什麼我就覺得
我很不屑一些研究
因為那些我都經歷過
我又跟你講講一個笑話
2008年的時候一堆人在討論
在11月的時候一堆人在討論
哇 過台明天的時候說景氣壞三倍啦
結果後來股價漲三倍啊
也不能怪他啊
因為大家很悲觀啊
大家在那邊 營業現金流
人家Google也好
特斯拉也跟你講
馬上就回報了
我算地還可以租出去
我不想每個租出去嘛
我自己都不夠用你在說什麼東西
你們看這些短期財報要幹什麼
見數不見零啊
你告訴我去年的時候
姐姐說台股3萬6
12月3號的時候很敢喊
很敢喊
大家每個都覺得我瘋了
我告訴你就是破5萬點啦
我告訴你5年內就10萬點啦
5年內10萬點很保守你知不知道
你為什麼4萬3 4萬點你在想什麼東西
4萬給我就買下去
買個至少7000萬
我可以答應的話
7000萬 8000萬
買就買嘛
我沒差
老天爺要多送幾千萬給我
我就花啊
I don't care
你相信我看的
我跟你講
你們這樣這就是你要看的分析師
每個人都講AI都懂AI
真的誰懂嗎
別家透過真的誰懂嗎
你不要
你們都不懂沒關係
你告訴我誰的圖做的
比我們某個的還好看
我不像人家 你告訴我嘛
莉莉你自己看
你看什麼牙科比猜想
然後怎麼做什麼顏色這些
數學吸血鬼
我也不要跟你講那麼多東西
就是他只要怎麼樣
映射到不同點點A
映射到可能點A'
點B點B'
點C點C'
不是 他映射到可以同一點了
代表這個例子
這反例啊 代表這不存在
你看我舉這麼簡單
這已經夠簡單的例子喔
一般A人很懂嘛
一般 你有AI 你有大刀
那你不會切啊
你有刀那你不會切菜啊
你告訴我誰做的圖能比我們漂亮
還有Fed的升級這東西
還人性這些東西
特斯大財報
Google財報
真的懂AI
我真的懂AI
不然我不會百萬粉絲
我跟你講
五年內
快一點四年甚至三年
台灣股市上10萬點
你跟不跟
跟
當然跟啦
你跟不跟
跟
好不好
OK
如果上10萬現在就可以買了
不用怎樣
不用跌回10萬
沒有錯啊
第一個我本來就有一大筆資金買40型ETF
買台灣50買納斯達克的ETF
我就跟你講過
只是
我跟你講
因為你們要把我當省嘛
當省是什麼意思
就是你們希望我買到很低點
我就買4萬元
如果我不單神
我現在全部all in了啦
沒差啊 你懂意思吧
是
我也買很多了
所以我沒有很計較錢
你知道嗎
我真的沒有很計較錢
你們喜歡單神
我就眼神給你看
就這麼簡單
好不好
這懂我意思嗎
來喔
來
來來來
再跟大家講
跟不跟
跟啦
閉著眼睛跟
跟著
請問哲哲
中國的AI發展會影響台灣嗎
當然會啊
打戰越來越難打
一個人關了
我在講 我講政治
我講以後的戰爭就是機器人戰爭
中國AI會發展台灣
以後戰爭機器人戰爭
台灣科技越差越多啦
我也不用登錄了啦
你知道嗎以後沒有什麼潛水艇
沒有用的啦
我一個無人機器把你轟炸啦
你潛水艇要幹什麼
你那個艦隊要幹什麼
你知道為什麼荷母之海峽
你覺得很奇怪喔
荷母之海峽是現在的存在嗎
還是存在很久了
幾千年了沒錯吧
對啊 很久了
那為什麼依然現在用
荷姆治海峽這招用的有效
以前沒效
是不是好問題
是耶
那你知道荷姆依然的旁邊
荷姆治海峽存在多久啊
幾千年了吧
是
那為什麼以前不用這招
現在用這招
為什麼啊
因為現在有無人機啊
有AI加上無人機啊
所以你有個無敵艦隊沒有用啊
我只要花個十萬美金 幾萬美金
我就五六台 幾十台
你怎麼樣
你要愛國者飛彈
就真的要
沒有用啊 你懂不懂
我低成本去消耗你
所以以後中國一對待台灣這樣子
拿著機器人登錄你就好了
你不要心 你看一下
來看一下
剛剛有人說
中國的發展對台灣怎麼樣
可是你不要去想這些東西
你想著每天中國要征服
你不覺得難過嗎
我就講這種件事
就不要刺激他嘛
我不論誰當領導
你們不要刺激他
這你不愛台灣整天
莫名其妙就是
就是不要刺激他
你記住我這件事
我為你們好
不要刺激人家
你懂不懂
懂
真的因為打仗的都是你啊
只在過幾年
欸
我是少衛輔導長
我好像60歲才能處一
都不要打仗
好 扯遠的
可是這個跟AI有關係
你看一下
你看一下這個
這中國的機器你看一下
剛好我要討論到東西
AI也是很恐怖啊
你就美國被跟上了
你看一下
你懂不懂
這打仗啊你看
真的 因為打仗
都被他以前的
只在過幾年
吐了
來來
聲音喔
來來來
他是不是關掉了
他把他踢擋不到
他就把他踢擋
跳舞了
他跳得比較好嗎
他腰交互
他快起來了
有反應力有沒有
他跳有沒有看到
還這樣給手甩手
國靈火啊
前陣營可不可以登陸台灣啊
是不是很誇張
有沒有嚇到
也太濕滑了吧
太濕滑
你又濕滑了
這OK吧
好 扯遠了
我們不要講政治
我只要告訴你
以後機器人真的可以取代人類
現在已經越來越多了
然後機器人高度大賽
我就跟你講
那時候有沒有
今年的
我不講說今年的那個
央視嗎
春晚
有沒有
去年機器人還會跌倒
還會怎麼樣
還是手拿著那個像什麼
彩帶嗎
彩帶 類似彩帶
不是彩帶 那是毛巾
不是毛巾
扇 反正類似彩帶的東西
以前要板著
是現在不是現在是可以拿著以前是板上去的現在可以拿著還可以跳舞活動的舞一堆人說這中國造假
也沒有
我要告訴你
我不是宣揚中國的好
現在AI最強的是什麼
美國
機器人最強的是中國
我跟你說這話
應用最強的是中國
接下來怎麼樣
可是中國強的
就像以前無人機
以前無人機
哇 中國就有很多表演
現在台灣有很多無人機表演的
是不是
最近不是好像台北市有一些什麼煙火啊
好
所以越來越多無人機的表演
也是模仿中國啊
大家都說模仿來模仿去
AI應用越來越多
我不要稱讚中國
我知道有人聽得不高興
這不是重點
我是要告訴大家
每個國家都會發展AI
那需要誰
需要AI伺服器
AI的變化跟很多
網路是能減長你壽命是不是啊
所以很多人他2000年網路泡沫
他們根本不懂啊
你知道嗎
XX筆記錄啊
懂我還說什麼了嗎
你們要懂得看到未來
我關鍵每天講那麼多資訊
你告訴我誰跟你講
每天
喔唷 AI 股
喔喔喔喔
PGB裡面
喔我這邊的組件
CPU裡面
講得頭頭是大
幹嘛
要幹嘛
那個我背一背就可以了
找稿子背就好了
我看到是未來
懂不懂
不需要
你懂不懂
真的不需要
我要跟你講就是
你說十萬點
隨時都可以買
沒有錯
我是講一次
十萬點
因為我每天
我的目標
我的點位
隨著它這些AI的發明
AI的進步
我股價越來高
你懂什麼
油居一吃怎麼可能回到百歲
但吃那個致癌油也不好
如果你們講多變政治化了
罵那好不好
我必然得罪
得罪
得罪政府或得罪誰
我都不想
好不好
好啦好啦
台中一台結局
好
政治奔動
停
Stop
可是你們
我只能講
我講說不要刺激對方就好了
好不好
我們也不要刺激什麼藍白綠
都不要刺激好不好
是
好 OK
STOP
聽鳥一帝
這樣
所以不要講政治好不好
講股票
超票是我們唯一的共識
好不好
OK嗎
OK
來
好啦好啦
不要講毒
不要講
不要講那個
他竟然跳舞跳到一半腿斷了
好啦好啦
不要不要不要
我們不講什麼
尚凱道
他要查水表
不會我沒講什麼
以後就走魔鬼者總結系列
靠奇奇怪的戰爭
以後就是了 好不好
夜盤拉200 有沒有看到
對啊 大造成煙火不是無人機表演
對啊
來來
所以我告訴你
那這時候是AI的應用
你們拜託
而且AI的應用
我又講你的事
你這個應用來來
網路的發明是這樣子
一般的發明
一般人的學習習慣是這樣子
沒有錯吧
對不對
對
那大家覺得
很多人覺得 哇
然後一般學習慣是這樣子
很多人覺得
快一點的話 進展快一點是這樣子 對不對
45度嘛 對不對
對
好
網路的
那是網路可能網路這樣發明
機器人 AI 的發明
的進展是這樣子
直線耶
一開始幾乎直線
後來基本上就是直線
一開始還稍微慢一點點
後來是直線
越一直越一直越一直越一直
同一個時間 這時間軸
這是時間
Time
這時間軸
一個時間軸
我們一直發明
無限發明
影響它的只有電力 土地 資源
你又能阻礙 AI 只有拔電的時候
拔掉電
OK
所以要記得我講這些東西好不好
OK 好啦
大家不要再講政治講別的東西
講政治我不理你 我們要把它刪掉
紅海 紅海 真厲害
紅海 新低量或新低價
我們就跟你講 像去桿桿一定低量
你不要再辣了
好不好
你們沒加折承會員
買在1010元
環球金喔
環球金我買更低的
買5、600元
好不好
OK嗎
來
三大法人賣0.96億
今天賞戶在自賣
去幹桿吧
如果中國AI會超越美國
那我買的股票
將會還有用嗎
你的邏輯不對
那你講的
如果中國
我有說中國一定會征服我們
就算中國征服我們
你就不要活了是不是
唉 我跟你講 30年前 40年前
就是一堆人這樣子移居美國
最後又移來台灣 房子都賣掉了
不要想這些
你們不要去管那種
你們不能掌握的名譽
去美國比較好
我認識一堆人去美國
都馬不開心
去美國比較好
那不是你的文化 你懂不懂
你就是會被歧視
但我不好意思
我的Lily在這邊講
因為Lily以前可能不存在美國
我講的是
我看一眼知道
那環境不是你的
好不好 你想被歧視嗎
確實是有問題的
你也覺得
你看東南亞人怎麼看
就是美國人怎麼看
我們已經算很少歧視對東南亞人了
我跟大家講
好不好 扯遠的
所以不要去想那些東西
你想那些幹什麼
中國會不會征服台灣那兩碼子事情
我現在問你是
十萬點你賺不賺嘛
是不是
我說沒錯吧
沒錯
十萬點你賺不賺
賺
賺不賺
你真的擔心
你就去買納斯達克ETF
我說真的啦
好不好
我說真的
你擔心東西
我覺得最好就是你都買
好不好 都買一些
台灣的股票也買一些
你資產喔
沒有5億以上
拜託你不需要做什麼配置好不好
好不好 我是認真的
我不是酸你啦
沒有意義
我講這實在話 你相信我
年輕人就拚一把
拚一把不要融資
你們真的要槓桿很簡單嘛
怎麼簡單
第一個你不要借錢
你要槓桿
你可以做權證啊
對
你可以做選擇權啊
是
頂多就是零嘛
是不是
跟你做槓桿
你的零你要賠錢喔
你知不知道
你怎麼知道
你知道是零喔
你知道是零
你要部分資金嘛
假如你100萬
你衝個30萬嘛
是不是
OK
你年輕人
我覺得你拚一把沒問題
可是你風險自負
你不要有怪鍋子喔
我同意是告訴你
不要這樣說
拚一把
年輕人要拚一把
不要想那麼多喔
每天單心中單心
幹什麼
機會
我看的是機會
所以你看我看的是機會
環球金拉回我就買
548萬中美金
我跟你講拉回我就要買
中美金我本來210幾我就要買
現在有到204多甜
所以你要清醒
有些股票本來我就要買了
我本來看起來
我看得起來以為要破底了
哲哲講的是對的
居然是要到5萬點甚至10萬點
請問你中美金買204塊
是買215塊有差嗎
請問你台灣股市買4萬點
還是4萬3有差嗎
對 哲哲有差
我就要買4萬點
前提是4萬點一定要到料
又不一定到了
是
不一定到了 你就隨便買就好了
就是這麼簡單好不好
也是一樣
5347世界先進
是不是 我問你
現在價錢比之前
公司賣在160元
台積電賣掉它還慘
這邊160元有沒有
這邊有跌停板有沒有
有
跳功跌停板
再看一次
有沒有
對啊
這邊有跌停板嗎
是
這邊價格我對過去喔
是不是現在更低
來 關大
是不是更低 關大
現在價格比那時候跌跌板還低
怕什麼啦
我最看好什麼
細晶圓
因為記憶體越缺
膳油越缺
膳油什麼
需要細晶圓
成熟製程呢
台積電呢
需要細晶圓
然後呢
指責
今天這麼慘
怎麼國劇這麼慘
我也覺得國劇今天殺的有點慘
來啦 謝謝啦
我就大謀報告越出越沒水準
我不是每次要嗆他
我覺得不能這樣子啦
好不好
我覺得大謀真的不能這樣子
沒有這種出報告的啦
我覺得台灣真的是分析師很好玩
那講下去
因為我講話很有影響力
我怕講下去
可是我跟你講
你可以大謀出去報告
樂觀情境200075
悲觀情境685
他已經從685國劇的價格
目標價到2075
都有寫進去啦
是
好 685的國劇也算他贏啦
2075的國劇也算他贏啦
你覺得這個是胡扯
你乾脆你國劇100到1萬
都算你贏就好啦
我講沒錯吧
沒錯
國劇的目標價也有
要嘛就2075
要嘛悲觀點685
還有標準情緝1465
我標準情緝1465很厲害喔
很厲害喔
我問你一件事情
國劇現在多少錢
600多塊
結果又多少錢
沒錯吧
沒錯
這個目標價厲害
什麼叫厲害
這目標價
他這個目標
從國軍的目標價大模
從685到2075都算他贏
結果現在的價格
還沒到這個range
還沒到這個範圍
不如不要寫
這樣寫報告的
我如果跟你講
來喔
環球金
之前1400嗎
對
1500嘛
環球金現在標準的賺塊
是1000元
悲慘一點是500元
好一點是3000元
你要接受我
參加我會員喔
500到3000都算我贏
不要
你要參加我會員嗎
要不要嘛
想不想參加我會員
不太想
不太想啊
我跟你講環球金
500到3000都算我贏
都是文物要這樣
還是這樣說的喔
然後有人說什麼
我跟你講他們這些都是菜米喔
你問那些博士
2018年的時候國具
在8年前的時候
你們有沒有寫國具報告
我寫過啦不好意思啦
應該說我叫底下研究員寫的啦
我有看過我親筆的撰寫一些東西啊
不好意思我講一講我肥大激動
拜託他們有經歷過被坑殺的感覺
前期賣股票
我是不好意思講欸
前妻跟陳代明同一洞瓏
這是新聞講的 我沒記錯
這麼小小
好賣那麼漂亮
賣900多塊
1000塊賣900多塊
好像找個阿布達比
金金啊
是
那時候賣得很漂亮耶
我跟你講
他現在
不要我講
我講的
我講以後
大家都會怕
我跟你講
除非春田製作所的股價
一直拉串心高
不然他沒本錢的啦
籌碼面真的大家都怕死了
所以你看
我講的新聞
你看
2146塊
大摩跟那個誰
是不是跟神之花旗是不是一樣的目標價
都真的很扯
你告訴我為什麼可以2028年
那我不是說不可能啦
然後如果一個背負元件就可以從20元到246元
我告訴你那你可以買更多的AI股
你不一定要買國具啊
懂不懂
OK嗎
他們沒有想到是什麼
729號週三嘛
週三的法說會很重要
週三法說會公佈禮拜四喔
沒有漲
沒有漲超過1%
我跟你講國具一定被落跑
沒救的機率極高
除非春田製作所
14號給我春田製作所
從300 早上1200
因為春田製作所
現在股價跟國際很像
是
大家給你看一下
春田製作所
你看 所以我懂
我又懂AI
又懂真的AI
從上游 下游
從細機能
我重到被動元件
誰真的我懂誰比我懂你如果這個時候你看到每個分析師每天還給你賺錢那不可能這種行情每天賺錢可是我告訴你我很多會員放久一點是真的賺很多
最近的不敢講
可是之前賺很多
我一堆股票還在賺錢
所以為什麼
最近還是一堆人參加我會員
因為他們知道我真的
這種行情回檔了
還是好多人在賺錢
所以你要找一個實在的分析師
不是嘴巴說
懂AI不是嘴巴說
你懂AI不是嘴巴說
你從我做的圖
從我敘述的AI機器人
等我跟你講這些國劇
然後跟你講2018年我的慘痛死
慘遭滑鐵爐
我告訴你
我是一步一步往上爬的
所以我這些績效才是實在的
看一次我績效才是實在的
我請問你100多萬粉絲
哪一個績效給你造假
你得到要講啊
哪顆啦
兩三次啊
就整理會賣費
I don't care
我不能選別的股票喔
我這次賺61
你到底要怎麼樣是不是
是啊 那時候破線我就先走不行喔
看起來連發科我就賣得很漂亮啊
是不是 沒錯
你看一下連發科現在多少
今天還跌70元耶
怪怪的
連發科今天還跌70元耶
等一下喔
有啦 蓮包哥
真慘了 你是要
金金你看一下
金金是要 對不起
都沒談對了 莉莉
不好意思 原油團隊太多人了
莉莉 你看一下
金來疊70元
真的
我賣4000元以上有什麼差別
我跟你講
我那時候說喊1萬塊的外資亂喊
那你說不再1萬塊
有可能台灣股市一直漲
等到10萬點
這些股票當然有機會翻杯
問題是
你要選件事我
當初我叫你
台積電換成年發科有沒有錯
台積電兩千多元
換成年發科一千多元有沒有錯
是對的
現在我告訴你年發科要出掉
我這個節奏如果拉長一點是很強
我告訴你被動元件
你現在能救他的只有一句話
春田製作手
其他不要多說
為什麼
國際是不是從300元
專業性我跟你講
我都很
你們被動元件你看這個就好了
你看啊 國際是從245元沒錯吧
放大放大這邊
看有沒有放大
245元對不對
一路漲到1220有沒有看到
是不是要300漲到1200
他說245漲到1200嘛對不對
是
再從1200掉到600元嘛對不對
沒錯吧
在看的時候
245漲到1220嘛對不對
好
看一下
春天製作所有沒有看到
也是200多啊
280幾
漲到
說錯了
是2821除以10啊
沒錯吧
是不是 剛才不是220幾嗎
對
282除以10啊
2821嘛
漲到12895嘛
12895嘛 對不對
對
是沒有錯吧
所以那個時候
你看他跟國具亦步亦趨
沒有錯吧
沒錯
20082到12895元
大概除以10就是國具的股價
好像很尷尬
那為什麼除以10像8102元
國具應該要800 700多元
為什麼要
因為現在那隻嚇跑了
突然想到2018年的PTSD
這還是有影響力的好不好
那很恐怖好不好
我認為高層還是有可能會賣股票
好不好
因為他實在太愛玩資本遊戲了
這沒辦法
我沒有說
可是我還是要講調的時候
我覺得可能國際高層也會看我節目
陳代銘也會看我節目
我們要得罪人
這沒什麼人家就厲害嘛
你懂不懂
他就繼續玩玩這遊戲
有些少過去不想跟
我不想跟啦
反正我賺到就好了
是不是
就這麼簡單
除非春聯製作所
能在創新高
再考慮好不好
沒錯吧
他12895嘛
Twist不就是1289元嗎
對
國劇也差不多1220元嘛
等到他突破13000元
那國劇就有機會突破1200
有可能喔
但是我覺得現在越來越難喔
因為國劇的籌碼亂掉
OK嗎
借件事國劇的籌碼亂掉好不好
啊沒有節目像我講的這麼厲害啦
好不好
來
這次省我服了
謝謝大家
記得這禮拜
春年不就了
有可能啊
一堆人國際追高睡公園的
所以不是還有人說什麼
好像徐乃玲的兒子說要追高睡公園
可惜他可能比較少看哲哲節目啦
好不好
好 來
大摩這樣是蠻酷的
對啊 目標叫這樣寫
國際買的高價
這是很悲劇
就是再過十年吧
跟台灣一樣
再過十年賺錢嘛
好不好
哲哲比外資更懂國際國家
因為那些外資或那些頭薪
都經過2018年都震亡
很多都震亡你知道嗎
是
只是東山再起
靠著什麼韓運股啊
靠著選股冠軍188%啊
哇 一直復活
不好意思
就像星星一樣
哇 之前有人要搞
成立什麼製救會
齁 星星人還要告我
結果
我不只是不起訴
我還簽結
所以都想要反告回去
我是認真認真說的
莫名其妙
我花幾百萬幾千萬都沒問題
我算是同業真的不要亂搞來搞去
因為不會增加業績
這件事
不會增加業績
好不好
好啦 這跟大家講
這比大謀哥會喊價
我喊的至少我很實在
我告訴你
譬如說
可是我不會講目標價
我覺得環球金2000元是小case
你記得我這句話
好不好
唯一的意思
我們第一個不喊目標價
第二個不代表未來保證
沒有這回事
好不好
會講未來保證
百分之二也是不合法的
我不做這件事情
OK嗎
我不急著去收這些回源
我不需要
這跟大家講
我們是合法的分析師
5P要慢慢賺
賺不完啦
環球金我們看一下公賀的簡訊
你看那時候靠跌停的時候
靠股災的時候買有沒有看到
靠股災的時候買
後來漲到一倍
漲到1485元有沒有看到
想一下幾分呢
好買進648萬環球金
掛在1035元買進
你買進不用再買有沒有看到
三禮拜還在買
低到高
蠟快6% 我買進到現在
最高的已經大賺93%
我本來這次環球金融
不可以普通會員買
因為一千多元的 幹嘛買什麼
可是普通會員還是可以買零股
問題是我
我應該是可以特工會員買高價股
你知道為什麼環球金融
我會給普通會員買嗎
你知道什麼嗎
為什麼
因為環球金融
我從五六百元買起
那時候不算高價股吧
是
不算一千元以上高價股吧
所以那時候普通會員有進場
只是買一買買成一個高價千金股啊
你看我的股票買一買
買到普通我也不知道要不要買
是
從低價股中價股變高價股
環球金賺93%
唉 沒什麼了
我覺得環球金沒有200%
我沒有考慮要走
我沒有 目前沒有
不代表以後
比如說你每天要看我的節目
好不好 你看
人家說哲哲 紅海是很厲害
我就說
我說紅海也是一樣
紅海也是一樣
我不懂啦
紅海我不懂了
如果你不是要等
你是可以天長地久的
我覺得鴻海是不錯的選擇
對不對 這線圖很漂亮
好不好 OK嗎
記我這句話好不好
很多股票
6196帆軒今天跌3%比較多
可是帆軒這一波你看根本沒跌
你懂不懂
所以我覺得他是有機會再拉上來
但我叫你這樣追也不好意思
你懂不懂我意思嗎
他就是有點牛啦 好不好
337是精彩
其實我一直想買
但他跌的不夠多
他只能跌不多
他能跌不多啊
他投資沒有門
好不好
這有跌20%嗎
沒有吧
是不是
沒有沒有沒有
快20當然沒有20
你知道嗎
沒有沒有沒有沒有20%
47%而已
從418元跌到3
放大放大
345元
朋友
金採因為之前我記得
我都是一兩百元買的
你知道嗎
他就一兩百元買了
300多元
等他見二字頭再說
所以我跟你講
我寧願股票回檔深一點
環球金要不是
他給我回檔35%以上
要不是環球金給我怎麼樣
從1600元有沒有看到
回檔到今天的有沒有看到
多少 我們來看一下
今天的多少
105元
從1600元回檔到今天105元
回檔了快40%
我還真的不敢買
因為我賺太多了
我買 我要是我追1600
我不是被會員罵死嗎
我幫人家抬轎
算這股票一般人抬不起來
那麼有價有量
動成幾百億的股票
可要不是他回答40%
我還不敢叫新一批的人埋進
就是因為他回答那麼多
創造無敵機會給我
真的
我很謝謝這次回答
從美金也是這樣
所以你一些舊股票
你想要進場的
有些回答很深的
我認同股票
你趕快來找我好不好
5347世界先進也是一樣
要不是他回答那麼多
回答2714
我看一下
148.5
注意到
他後來不是回答剛好三五法則
回答34%
是
就是乘以0.66
回答34%
要不是葉建基回答34%
我說老實話
我現在還不敢叫新會員
一直買進
所以你去想想看你要怎樣分心事好不好
想清楚想明白
微星今天又給我偷拉尾盤
我覺得最猛的可能是微星
微星可能要噴出去
精彩也是有機會
精彩最近比較弱
可是微星怎麼樣都不弱
你不覺得嗎
為什麼微星不弱
因為低基期啊
我選的股票低基期
所以你去想想看
你要知道什麼意思好不好
想清楚想明白
哇哲哲你的股票真的很飆
哲哲真的像你講的
你看到的是機會
我不應該看到的是悲觀的命運
應該看到的是機會
我機會的命運改變我人生
所以你真的認同我
哇想到去年好好多
主播討論我哲哲怎麼那麼敢喊
喊3萬6次喊4萬
瘋了很多時候很敢喊
現在看起來我告訴你好不好
那時候我就有九成把握
我告訴你那現在我九成
我把握今年5萬點以上
然後我有9成5以上的把握
我要告訴你怎麼樣
5年內甚至4年內
台灣股市上10萬點
然後我請問你
我請問你一件事
你要不要現在進場
你要的話
要齁
要不要現在進場
要
你要的話
歡迎來進場
請080668085
加我LINE
私訊我
找全台灣最豪的分析師
唯一百萬分析師
預告在前最懂AI的分析師
歡迎來一起來請 0806 8085
加我來你私訊
我說哲哲 我要賺到錢
哲哲 請問會費多少
我捷盡我所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 掰掰
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险